le temps est compté 24 heures de retard
dans une livraison et c'est la
catastrophe
bernard andrieu président des foies gras
sarrade vie toutes les fins d'années à
ce rythme effréné
c'est un bon signe les stocks fondent
comme grèce au soleil la période
actuelle est cruciale pour l'entreprise
les trois dernières semaines de décembre
représente 50% du chiffre d'affaires
annuel
ces derniers jours des camions gaver de
foie gras ont sillonné toute la france
et à 400 à 500 mille francs dans un
camion
donc hier il est parti pratiquement
quinze camions dans mon pire c'était une
journée
kiva lanta 7 millions sept minutes et
demie bien sûr la production doit suivre
horaires adaptés emplois saisonniers
tout est prévu pour qu'en fin d'année on
fasse la fête aux canards cette semaine
on va passer trois amis les bêtes
qu ils soient souples il ne faut pas
qu'il soit dure deux fois parce que le
poids du rck fois de plein de graisse
programme de qualité strictes normes
d'hygiène la production industrielle de
foie gras c'est en disant totalement
transformé mais le consommateur ne s'y
retrouve pas toujours un peu perdu entre
le haut de gamme le foie gras entier et
le bas de gamme
intelligemment appelé bloc de foie gras
sans compter que certains producteurs
d'autres régions de france ont parfois
un goût prononcé pour des marques qui
sonne sud ouest je prendrai un exemple
une marque n'existe pas le canard des
landes
alors là il a vraiment obligation de
n'utiliser que du choix landais ou
d'imposer sur l'étiquette une mention
correctives précisant que ce produit a
été élaboré avec des fois importée car
dans ce cas il ya vraiment un risque de
confusion pour le consommateur
faire la chasse aux vilains petits
canards c'est l'objectif de l'igpn
indication géographique protégée vie gp
c'est d'abord une certification
d'origine pour revendiquer lee gp sud
ouest les produits doivent être élaborés
avec des canards hellweg avait abattus
et transformés dans la région c'est
ensuite un cahier des charges strict
pour l'ensemble de la filière
vous voyez ici les animaux sont dehors
c'est une caractéristique de cette
production on ne peut pas lever de
canard pour faire des foies gras sans
qu'ils aient un accès à l'extérieur
concrètement à partir de l'été prochain
les gp sud ouest ce sera ce logo il aura
fallu six ans aux professionnels de la
région pour boucler le dossier à
bruxelles
l'enjeu parfois inavoués se protéger des
autres producteurs notamment vendéen qui
en six ans ont raflé 20 % du marché et
ne pourra plus être fait référence à
cette région qui a encore une fois
apporte la porte la mémoire collective
du foie gras il pourra plus être fait
référence à cette région en isère
et puisque nous vivons à l'ère des
sigles nous vous recommandons pour les
fêtes un bbb- avec j'ai eu un bon verre
de blanc avec du foie gras entier